LIKE HEZBOLLAH.
WE’LL COVER THAT AND MUCH
MORE IN TONIGHT’S BREAKING
NEWS OPENING MONOLOGUE.
♫
♫ ALL RIGHT.
BEFORE WE GET INTO ALL THE
NEWS WE HAVE TONIGHT, ON
THIS SHOW WE’RE NEVER GOING
TO FORGET THAT HILLARY
CLINTON YOU WE NOW KNOW
RIGID THE PRIMARY AGAINST
BERNIE SANDERS.
WE’RE NOT GOING TO FORGET
THAT HER EXONERATION WAS
WRITTEN BEFORE THE
INVESTIGATION WAS EVEN NEAR
COMPLETE ON THE PRIVATE
EMAIL SERVER.
WE’RE NOT GOING TO FORGET
THAT A PHONY DOSSIER, BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR BY HILLARY
CLINTON WITH RUSSIAN LIES
WAS USED TO GET A FISA COURT
WARRANT AGAINST CARTER PAGE
EVEN THOUGH THE FBI NEVER
VERIFIED THE INFORMATION.
ON THIS SHOW, WE’RE GOING TO
STAY ON THIS STORY UNTIL WE
GET JUSTICE.
NOW, ON TO TONIGHT’S
DEVELOPMENTS.
NOW, WE HAVE TWO SHOCKING
REPORTS, BOTH FROM THE "NEW
YORK TIMES" AND THE
INTERCEPT.
THEY ARE RAISING SERIOUS
QUESTIONS THIS HOUR ABOUT
JUST HOW FAR THE DEEP STATE
WILL GO TO DAMAGE PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
NOW, ACCORDING TO THESE
REPORTS, AMERICAN SPIES LAST
YEAR MET WITH UNNAMED
RUSSIAN WHO WAS THOUGHT TO
HAVE TIES TO RUSSIAN
INTELLIGENCE.
NOW, THE AMERICAN OFFICIALS
WERE INTERESTED IN
RECOVERING POWERFUL CYBER
TOOLS THAT HAD BEEN HACKED
BUT THIS RUSSIAN PERSON
QUICKLY CLAIMED TO HAVE,
QUOTE:  COMPROMISING
MATERIAL ON PRESIDENT TRUMP.
NOW, THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
DOES REPORT THAT THE
AMERICAN INTELLIGENCE
OFFICIALS SAY THEY WERE ONLY
INTERESTED IN RETRIEVING THE
NSA CYBER WEAPONS BUT THE
RUSSIAN WAS EAGERLY PUSHING
ANTI-TRUMP INFORMATION WHICH
INCLUDED 15 SECOND VIDEO OF
AN AMERICAN BUSINESSMAN IN A
ROOM TALKING TO TWO WOMEN.
AND ACCORDING TO THE TIMES,
THERE WAS NO WAY TO VERIFY
WHO WAS IN THAT VIDEO AND
THE AMERICAN SPIES THOUGHT
IT WASN’T CREDIBLE.
AMERICAN OFFICIALS
EVENTUALLY AGREED TO PAY
SHADOWY RUSSIAN $100,000.
INSTEFDZ TURNING OVER NSA
HACKING TOOLS, HE GAVE THEM,
QUOTE, UNVERIFIED AND
POSSIBLY FABRICATED
INFORMATION INVOLVING
MR. TRUMP AND OTHERS,
INCLUDING BANK RECORDS,
EMAILS AND PURPORTED RUSSIAN
INTELLIGENCE DATA.
THE 100 GRAND WAS SUPPOSED
TO BE THE FIRST INSTALLMENT
OF $1 MILLION THEY WERE
GOING TO PAY OUT WHICH WAS
DOWN TO 10 MILLION THAT THE
RUSSIAN ORIGINALLY WAS
ASKING FOR.
THE TIMES ALSO NOTES SINCE
THE PHONY ANTI-TRUMP DOSSIER
AUTHORED BY CHRISTOPHER
STEELE CAME OUT LAST YEAR
THERE HAVE WITHIN AT LEAST
FOUR RUSSIANS WITH ESPIONAGE
CONNECTIONS AND THEY HAVE
TIED TO SELL DAMAGING
INFORMATION TO POLITICAL
OPERATIVES SPIES AND
INVESTIGATORS.
ALSO ACCORDING TO THE
"TIMES" REMEMBER CODY
SHEARER LONG-TIME CLINTON
ALLY WHO WOULD WRITE A
SECOND FAKE NEWS DOSSIER?
QUOTE:  HE HAS BEEN
CRISSCROSSING EASTERN EUROPE
FOR MORE THAN SIX MONTHS TO
SECURE THE PURPORTED
COMPROMISING MATERIAL FROM A
DIFFERENT RUSSIAN.
SO THERE IS A LOT OF
DIFFERENT INFORMATION TO
TAKE IN HERE.
LET ME TRY AND CONNECT THESE
DOTS FOR YOU.
U.S. INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS
PAYING $100,000 TO A RUSSIAN
WITH PURPORTED TIES TO
MOSCOW.
ENDS UP GIVING THEM
UNVERIFIED, POSSIBLY
FABRICATED ANTI-TRUMP
INFORMATION.
WHERE THAT INFORMATION IS
AND WHERE HO HAS THAT
INFORMATION WE DON’T KNOW.
THE CIA IS STRONGLY DENYING
THE INFORMATION BEING
REPORTED BY THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" AND THE INTERCEPT.
AND THE NSA REPORTEDLY
DECLINED TO PROVIDE A
COMMENT TO THE INTERCEPT.
AND ON TOP OF ALL OF THIS,
WE ARE ALSO LEARNING THAT AT
LEAST FOUR OTHER RUSSIANS
HAVE BEEN SHOPPING AROUND
COMPROMISING INFORMATION.
BY THE WAY, I THOUGHT THEY
LIKED TRUMP.
AND LONG-TIME CLINTON FRIEND
CODY SHEARER IS LITERALLY
GOING ALL OVER EUROPE TRYING
TO DIG UP DAMAGING DIRT
ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP FROM A
RUSSIAN.
HERE IS WHAT IT ALL MEANS
TONIGHT.
RUSSIA IS DOING EVERYTHING
THEY CAN DO TO SPREAD LIES
ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
DEMOCRATS WHO ARE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO ACCEPT IT THEY WILL
DO ANYTHING TO DAMAGE THE
PRESIDENT.
I THOUGHT THIS WAS THE
HORRIBLE THING TO DO.
I THOUGHT WE SPENT A YEAR
INVESTIGATING COLLUSION WITH
THE RUSSIANS.
WE HAVE DISCOVERED REAL
COLLUSION.
AND THESE NEW REPORTS ARE
OFFERING UP EVEN MORE
EVIDENCE THAT WE HADN’T SEEN
BEFORE.
NOW, WE ALREADY KNOW THAT
HILLARY CLINTON AND THE DNC,
THEY PAID OVER, WHAT,
$12 MILLION TO FUSION GPS?
THEY HIRED THE FORMER
BRITISH SPY CHRISTOPHER
STEELE.
HE CREATED THAT DOSSIER
FILLED WITH RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT LIES AND PROP
BEGAN DARKS SALACIOUS
MATERIAL.
CLINTON DID THAT WITH ONE
INTENTION SHE WANTED TO
IMPACT THE GENERAL ELECTION.
DIDN’T MATTER IF IT WAS
TRUTHFUL OR NOT.
THOSE TWO MEMOS AS THEY ARE
UNCOVERING HERE THE FBI AND
THE DOJ.
THEN THEY USE THE SALACIOUS,
UNVERIFIED DOSSIER OF
CHRISTOPHER STEELE TO GET A
WARRANT TO SPY ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND THEIR ASSOCIATE
CARTER PAGE.
AND ACCORDING TO THE MEMOS,
THE DOSSIER MADE UP THE
BULK, REMEMBER GRASSLEY AND
GRAHAM MEMO MADE UP THE BULK
OF THE FISA APPLICATION.
THEN THE FBI, JAMES COMEY
NEVER BOTHERED TO VERIFY IT
THEN THEY USED IT AND TO GO
TO BEFORE A FISA COURT IN AN
EFFORT TO SPY ON CARTER PAGE
AND THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN, THEY
NEVER SAID HILLARY CLINTON
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR IT AND
IT’S NOT VERIFIED AS THEY
SHOULD HAVE.
AS WE TELLING YOU ABOUT ON
FRIDAY POLITICO IS REPORTING
THAT FORMER WHITE HOUSE
CHIEF STRATEGIST STEVE
BANNON MAY HAVE BEEN PICKED
UP BY FBI SURVEILLANCE WHILE
CARTER PEARGE WAS BEING
SPIED ON.
STATE DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL
ACTUALLY ADMITTED IN OP-ED
HE WAS SHARING ANTI-TRUMP
OPPOSITION RESEARCH FROM
FRIENDS OF THE CLINTONS WITH
THE DOSSIER CREATOR
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
THIS IS ALL AN UNPRECEDENTED
ABUSE OF POWER.
THE CONSTITUTION IS BEING
SHREDDED BEFORE YOUR EYES,
CIVIL LIBERTIES ARE BEING
SEVERELY VIOLATED.
REMEMBER THE FOURTH
AMENDMENT PROTECTION AGAINST
UNREASONABLE SEARCH AND
SEIZURE?
AND, YES, IN SPITE OF WHAT
THE MEDIA IS TELLING YOU AND
DOWN PLAYING, IT IS BIGGER
THAN WATER GATE.
AS WE HAVE BEEN REPORTING A
LOT MORE INFORMATION IS
COMING OUT EVERY DAY.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE SIDE OF
YOUR SCREEN, THINK THIS IS A
SMALL SCANDAL?
SO FAR 14 OFFICIALS AT THE
DOJ AND THE FBI HAVE EITHER
BEEN FIRED, REASSIGNED,
DEMOTED OR QUIT.
THEY WANT TO GET OUT OF
THERE.
AND THERE ARE A LOT OF
OTHERS WHO ARE INVOLVED IN
WHAT IS BEING EXPOSED.
BUT SIMPLY BEING MOVED
AROUND THE BUREAUCRACY,
THAT’S NOT GOING TO BE GOOD
ENOUGH.
THAT’S NOT GOING TO SOLVE
THE PROBLEMS.
ALL OF THESE OFFICIALS ALL
NEED TO BE INVESTIGATED AND
THOSE THAT ARE GUILTY,
PROSECUTED TO THE FULLEST
EXTENT OF THE LAW SO THIS
NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN.
ALSO NEW TONIGHT, SENATOR
GRASSILY AND SENATOR GRAVEL
OF THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE ARE NOW DEMANDING
ANSWERS FROM PRESIDENT
OBAMA’S FORMER NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR SUSAN RICE.
NOW THEY DISCOVERED A
PARTIALLY UNCLASSIFIED EMAIL
THAT SHE ACTUALLY SENT TO
HERSELF ON PRESIDENT TRUMP’S
INAUGURATION DAY.
AND RICE, THROUGH THIS
EMAIL, APPEARS TO DOCUMENT A
JANUARY 5TH, 2017 OVAL
OFFICE MEETING BETWEEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA, FORMER FBI
DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY AND
FORMER DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL SALLY YATES
INVOLVING RUSSIAN
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
IN HER EMAIL RICE NOTES THAT
PRESIDENT OBAMA APPARENTLY
TOLD COMEY AND ORIOLES TO
HANDLE THINGS, QUOTE, BY THE
BOOK.
REALLY?
AND GRASSLEY AND GRAHAM ARE
STRUCK BY THE CONTEXT AND
THE TIMING OF THIS EMAIL AND
THEY HAVE NOW SENT OUT A
SERIES OF QUESTIONS FOR RICE
TO ANSWER BY FEBRUARY 22ND.
NOW, WHILE REPUBLICAN MEMOS
ARE PROVIDING DAMNING FAX
AND EVIDENCE ABOUT DEEP
STATE GOVERNMENT CORRUPTION,
THE DEMOCRATS THEY
DESPERATELY TRYING TO COVER
UP THE TRUTH.
THEY NEVER WANTED YOU TO SEE
THIS INFORMATION.
AND THEY ARE TRYING TO
CHANGE THE NARRATIVE.
THEY PUT OUT THEIR OWN
COUNTER MEMO AND ON FRIDAY
PRESIDENT TRUMP SENT THE
DEMOCRATS’ MEMO BACK TO THE
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
WITH A LETTER EXPLAINING
WHY.
BECAUSE IT CONTAINED
CLASSIFIED SOURCES AND
METHODS THAT COULD
JEOPARDIZE NATIONAL
SECURITY.
AND, OF COURSE, THE MEDIA
PRICK THATTABLY IGNORED ALL
OF THESE FACTS AND ATTACKING
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR BEING
ANTI-TRANSPARENCY.
BUT, OF COURSE, WE KNOW
THEY’RE LYING THE DEMOCRATS
WERE CLEARLY SETTING A TRAP
FOR THE PRESIDENT.
THEY WANTED HIM TO RELIES
CLASSIFIED MATERIAL WHITE
HOUSE DIDN’T FALL INTO THE
TRAP.
THE WHITE HOUSE WANT TO
RELEASE THE MEMO.
DEMOCRATS HAVE POLK MAT
NECESSARY EDITS NOT THE
PRESIDENT.
THE REPUBLICAN MEMO DID NOT
CONTAIN CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION.
IT DID THE NOT REVEAL
SOURCES AND METHODS.
SO WHY CAN’T THE DEMOCRATS
PLAY BY THE SAME RULES?
BECAUSE THE FACTS AREN’T ON
THEIR SIDE.
AND FOR RIGID, LEFT WINGERS
IN THIS COUNTRY AND MEMBERS
OF THE MEDIA THAT ARE
COMPLICIT CLAIMING THIS ALL
A PLAN TO BLOCK THE
DEMOCRATIC MEMO.
NOT AT ALL.
I SAY RELEASE THAT MEMO.
THEY CLEARLY DIDN’T READ THE
WHITE HOUSE LETTER OR LISTEN
TO THE HOUSE COMMITTEE
NUNES IS SAYING LIKE WE ARE
SAYING THAT HE WANTS THE
MEMO RELEASED.
I WANTS IT RELEASED.
TAKE A LOCK.
LOOK.>> WE ACTUALLY WANT THE
DEMOCRATIC MEMO OUT.
WE THINK IT’S RIDICULOUS ON
THE FACE OF IT.
THEY ATTACK MYSELF AND
CHAIRMAN GOWDY THEY TURN
CARTER PAGE INTO RUSSIAN
SPY.
CHRISTOPHER STEELE AS A GOOD
SOURCE WHEN WE KNOW HE LIED
TO THE FBI.
WE WANT THIS OUT.
WE DON’T KNOW WHY THEY ARE
NOT IN THIS WEEKEND WE
AMERICANS WITH DISABILITIES
REDACTING IT SO THEY CAN GET
IT BACK TO THE WHITE HOUSE
SO THE PRESIDENT CAN
DECLASSIFY IT.
>> Sean: THERE YOU HAVE IT
FOR REPUBLICANS THIS WHOLE
ISSUE HAS BEEN ABOUT TRUTH
AND TRANSPARENCY, FOR
DEMOCRATS THE LEFT WING
MEDIA ALL ABOUT PLAYING
POLITICS.
WE WILL HAVE MORE THAN IN A
MOMENT.
FIRST THE WINTER OLYMPICS IN
SOUTH KOREA BEGAN LATE LAST
WEEK BUT NOT WITHOUT SOME
CONTROVERSY.
NOW AFTER FRIDAY’S OPENING
CEREMONY, WELL, MEMBERS OF
THE ECHO CHAMBER SWUNG INTO
FULL GEAR TO HEAP PRAISE ON
A WOMAN NAMED KIM YO JONG
WHO JUST HAPPENS TO BE THE
DIRECTOR OF PROPAGANDA TORE
PROP PROPAGANDAROGUE DICTATORSH.
THAT DIDN’T STOP THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA FROM
FAWNING ALL OVER KIM YO JONG
SHOWING UP AT THE CEREMONIES
SHAKING HANDS WITH THE SOUTH
KOREAN PRESIDENT AND CALMLY
WATCHING THE OPENING
PROCESSION.
CNN, FAKE NEWS, THE WHOLE
NETWORK RAN THIS HEADLINE
KIM JONG UN’S SISTER
STEALING THE SHOW AT THE
WINTER OLYMPICS.
NORTH KOREA HEADS FOR
DIPLOMACY GOLD MEDAL AT
OLYMPICS AND NOT TO BE
OUTDONE THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
WRITES KIM JONG UN’S SISTER
TURNS ON THE CHARM TAKING
PENCE’S SPOTLIGHT.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" ALSO
TWEETS WITHOUT A WORD ONLY
FLASHING SMILES, KIM JONG
UN’S SISTER OUTFLANKED VICE
PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE AND
DIPLOMACY.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" NOT TO
BE OUTDONE CALLED KIMY.
O JONG THE IVANKA TRUMP OF
NORTH KOREA.
GLOWING COVERAGE CONTINUED
ON TV.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> ATHLETES FROM THE KNOT
AND SOUTH KOREA MARCHING ON
THE SAME TEAM WAVING
REUNIFICATION FLAGS.
MORE HISTORY JUST A FEW
SEATS AWAY.
KIM JONG UN’S SISTER RIGHT
THERE BEHIND THE VICE
PRESIDENT.
>> IN HISTORIC MOMENT SHOOK
THE HAND OF THE SISTER OF
THE NORTH KOREAN LEADER KIM
JONG UN.
>> THE SISTER OF KIM JONG UN
SHOOK HANDS WARM LIVE WITH
THE SOUTH KOREAN PRESIDENT
IN THE V.I.P. BOX OF
CEREMONIES.
>> NORTH KOREA IS STEALING
MUCH OF THE LIMELIGHT
AIRPORT EARLIER TODAY.
THREE DAYS OF THE WORLD’S
MEDIA RUNNING AFTER THE
SILLS TER OF NORTH KOREAN
LEADER KIM JONG UN AND STILL
WE KNOW VERY LITTLE ABOUT
THE WOMAN WHO HAS STOLEN THE
HEADLINES AT THE POCK CHANGE
WINTER OLYMPICS.
>> IF THAT’S NOT BAD ENOUGH
THE MEDIA ALSO GOES AFTER
VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE
FOR REFUSING TO SHAKE HER
HAND IN THE V.I.P. BOX.
WE HAVE MORE WITH THAT WITH
JOE CONCHA LATER IN THE
SHOW.
TAKE A STEP BACK AND
REMEMBER THE WOMAN THAT THE
MEDIA IS APPLAUDING IS THE
DIRECTOR OF PROPAGANDA FOR A
GOVERNMENT THAT HAS, LET’S
SEE, MURDERED ARRANGED
400,000 POLITICAL PRISONERS
IN WHAT SOME ARE CALLING
CONCENTRATION CAMPS AND
THESE CAMPS HAVE BEEN IN
EXISTENCE SINCE 1982?
AND AS WE SPEAK BETWEEN
80,000 AND 120,000 PEOPLE
ARE STILL IMPRISONED IN
THOSE CAMPS, INCLUDING MEN,
WOMEN, AND EVEN CHILDREN?
AND ACCORDING TO A 2014
UNITED NATIONS REPORT, WELL
OVER 200,000 PEOPLE FROM
AROUND THE WORLD HAVE SIMPLY
DISAPPEARED.
NEVER TO BE SEEN AGAIN
INSIDE OF NORTH KOREA.
DON’T FORGET THERE ARE THREE
AMERICANS CURRENTLY BEING
HELD HOSTAGE IN THAT ROGUE
STATE.
THE KIM JONG UN’S REGIME HAS
BEEN RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
RECENT DEATH OF AMERICAN
OTTO WARMBIER SENTENCED TO
HARD LABOR FOR ALLEGEDLY
STEALING A POSTER.
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE ARE
CURRENTLY STARVING INSIDE OF
NORTH KOREA.
ROUGHLY 30% OF THEIR
POPULATION STARVING ALL
WHILE THIS LITTLE DESPOT,
KIM JONG UN, LIVES A LIFE OF
LUXURY AND SISTER ENJOY AS
PRIME SEAT AT THE OPENING
GAMES OF THIS YEAR’S WINTER
OLYMPICS.
DESPITE ALL OF ALL OF THIS,
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
CONTINUES TO PRAISE KIM YO
JUDGE.
JONG.
KOREA.
GOOD DEAL FOR AMERICAN
PEOPLE THEY EVER NEVER GET
NUKES.
IF YOU DON’T LEARN FROM THE
PAST YOU ARE TOOMED TO
REPEAT IT THAT’S WHY THE
MEDIA IS A SAD AND
DESPICABLE RECORD.
SPEAKING OF BAD PLANS,
REMEMBER THE PLANE LOADS OF
1.7 BILLION IN DOLLARS IN
CASH AND OTHER CURRENCY FS
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
STEREOTYPEDLY GAVE THE
IRANIAN MULLEN LAS CHANTING
GTE TO AMERICA AND TEHRAN?
NOW WE ARE FINDING OUT THAT
THE ROGUE REGIME IS USING A
LOT OF THAT MONEY, THE
"WASHINGTON TIMES" REPORTING
THAT THE U.S. GOVERNMENT HAS
BEEN ABLE TO TRACE SOME OF
THE MONEY GIVEN TO IRAN AND